there is a half an apple pie left you
want to eat twice what your little
brother eats but you also need to save a
slice for your mom
you can cut her slice that it's 30
degrees what is the measure of your
piece of the pie in degrees so to tackle
this we just have to remember a few
things we have to remember that degrees
in a circle so if we were to go all the
way around a circle that that would be
360 degrees 360 degrees but we only have
half a pie here and actually let me draw
it a little bit differently so if we had
a whole pie so if we started here and if
we had a whole pie we went all the way
around that would be 360 degrees but we
only have a half pie so we only have 180
degrees and let me do that in a color
you're more likely to see it's hard to
see as well we only have 180 degrees of
pie left but let's just keep that in
mind and think about how we're going to
split it between ourselves our brother
and our mom so let's define some
variables let's let X be equal to the
degree measure of my brother's pie or
you brought your little brother's pie so
this is degree measure of brother's pie
brothers pie and then what would the
amount of pie you eat be what says you
eat twice what your little brother eats
so 2x would be equal what you eat what
you eat it's really the degree measure
of what you eat and then how much does
your mom eat well it says you cut her
slice that is 30 degrees so your mom's
gonna get a 30 degree slice gonna get a
slice something like that so the amount
that your brother eats X plus the amount
you eat plus the amount that your mom
gets plus 30 degrees is going to be
equal to this 1/2 pie and remember all
of these are degree measures so it's
going to be equal to 180 degrees and
just to visualize it over here and let
me do it down here where it's easier to
see it we have half a pie that we're
dealing with we're gonna save 30 degrees
we're going to save 30 degrees for our
mom so that's 30 degrees right over
there your brother is going to eat some
amount your brother is going to eat some
amount so that is X and then you're
going to eat twice that amount so that
is 2x X is the measure of this this
angle and then 2 X is a measure of that
angle so you see that 30 degrees plus X
plus 2 X or X plus 2 X plus 30 degrees
is going to be equal to 180 degrees now
we can simplify this if we have one of
something and then have another two of
it how much do we have now
well I now have three X's so 1 X plus 2
X's is going to be 3 X's so I have 3x
plus 30 degrees plus 30 degrees plus 30
degrees is going to be equal to of
course 180 degrees 180 degrees now to
solve for X we can subtract 30 degrees
from both sides so minus 30 degrees
minus 30 degrees and I could have just
written that I could have all assumed
that I'm doing it in degrees and just
done it at the end but I'm just keep
writing it so I'll just keep going with
that
and then we are left with we are left
with 3 X 3 X equaling 180 degrees minus
30 degrees is equal to 150 degrees 150
degrees and now we can just divide both
sides by 3 and divide both sides by 3
and we're left with X equaling 150
divided by 3 is 50 degrees X is equal to
50 degrees now we have to be careful X
is not the is not what they're asking
for they're asking for the measure of
your piece of pie in degrees X is the
degree measure of your brother's piece
of pie what you eat is 2 times that so
if X is 50 degrees if X is 50 degrees 2
times that is going to be 100 degrees so
what is the measure of your piece of the
pie in degrees it is going to be 100
degrees so if we draw our pie again if
we draw our half pie you have 30 degrees
for your mom so that's 30 degrees for
your mom you have 50 degrees for your
brother you have 50 degrees
for your brother and then you have twice
that for yourself 100 degrees